صحيفه وولشي جان الامريكيه عنون صراع مميت
على السلطه بين اكبر جنرالين في السودان
الصحيفه تقول ان الفشل في انهاء القتال
بسرعه ومعاوده المحادثات مع القاده
المدنيين قد يدفع السودان مره اخرى
للانزلاق الى حرب اهليه وفق محللين اما
صحيفه التيليجراف البريطانيه فعنونه حرب
بوتين انفجرت في السودان السودان يتصدع
تحت تاثير المرتزق الروس وقد يتم ربط قوات
الدعم السريع بمجموعه فاغنر التي قيل انها
ساعدت في تدريبهم وتجهيزهم قد تواجه تشاد
واريتريا وجنوب السودان طوفان من اللاجئين
ما يزيد من صراعاتهم الداخليه
الى صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه تحت
عنوان السودان يخشى من حرب اهليه بعد
انفجارات تهز العاصمه القتال في دارفور
عنصر قابل للاشتعال والصراع تعد دارفور
موطنا للعديد من الجماعات المتمرده التي
قد تنخرط في القتال صحيفه لوفيغرو
الفرنسيه عنونه التنافس بين العسكريين
يجعل الخرطوم تغرق في الفوضى على الرغم من
الدعوات العديده للهدوء من المجتمع الدولي
والقوى السياسيه السودانيه لا يبدو ان ايا
من الطرفين مستعد للتفاوض مصدر دبلوماسي
غربي في الخرطوم صرح للصحيفه بوجود عده
محاولات اقليميه ودوليه للمصالحه لكن
الامر معقد فالطرفان منخرطان في اسلوب
اللفظي وعسكري واحد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات